4 los más grandes tiroteos de la
historia de eeuu han promovido
propuestas de legislación para regular
la venta de armas ocurrió después de la
matanza de 26 personas en la escuela de
sandy hook en 2012 que ha sido la más
mortífera de la historia y también
ocurrió tras la balacera en un club
nocturno en orlando en 2016 explíquenos
por qué es tan difícil sacar adelante
dichas normas
pues buenas noches tenemos un problema
estructural del
en eeuu en que la industria de armas de
fuego es enorme es militarizado y es muy
permisivo entonces con una población de
4 por ciento de la población mundial
eeuu tiene casi la mitad de armas de
fuego en manos de civiles y yo diría que
también los republicanos en el congreso
también son comprados por la industria
de armas de fuego ellos nunca van a
votar para restricciones porque son
intimidados son comprados por por esa
industria y por sus adherentes entre las
comunidades y por otro lado los
autócratas
no tienen la suficiente mayoría para
superar ese resistencia de los
republicanos y no es solamente con
revisión de antecedentes con que se
puede realmente
universal
cambiar todo esto es una cultura es una
economía y son políticas de ley
estatales como federales que tenemos que
revertir
usted habla de dos razones principales
una del poder de la industria y dos la
debilidad de los demócratas pero
profundizamos un poco más en qué tan
fuerte es el lobby de las organizaciones
de armas en la política estadounidense
pues el lobby ha logrado de armas ha
logrado políticas que que blindan la
industria en contra de demandas civiles
también
leyes que protegen la información no hay
un registro de armas por ejemplo toda la
información que tiene el gobierno sobre
armas vendidas
a civiles están en el papel no están
computer ni computarizados entonces es
esa industria tiene ha logrado en la
estructura dificultades para hacer
cumplir con la ley y controlar el
mercado